foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsey
personality George Campbell join this
hour by the Rachel Cruz who is also my
co-host on Smart money happy hour that's
right which we're having a blast with I
appreciate all of you listening to that
subscribing sharing with Friends we just
released one about 90s Nostalgia and how
they're coming for our wallets with it
yeah people loved it it was great you
know there was an Instagram post people
were sending me uh Instagram handle
camera who it is but they go back to all
this Nostalgia uh moments of commercials
and catalogs so they have like the
JCPenney
1993 spring catalog girls and I was like
that was my there's my wardrobe that was
your aesthetic there it was so yeah it
was a fun episode go check that out well
we're taking your calls this hour at
triple eight eight two five
5225 you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money Neil is kicking us
off in Denver Neil welcome to the show
hey guys how you guys doing today great
how are you I'm doing great doing great
um just a little background on what's
going on here we just started baby stuff
number two my wife and I and I can't
tell you how
much of a difference it has made in our
life and even in my marriage already so
I really appreciate the work you guys do
that's awesome to hear
awesome well my question today I've
worked in lending for the past seven
years
um five of that doing lending and then
last two years in in lending Tech and
after starting the Dave Ramsey program
the baby stats I'm feeling a little bit
like I just don't want to be a part of
the problem
you know and I I've put people into more
debt before where they probably
shouldn't have gone and
um our Tech doesn't necessarily help
that it's a it's an education tool but I
just really don't want to have
um I'm just I'm struggling with it so I
was wondering what you guys
have for me
so you've been in the lending world and
the financial world are there other
companies roles that wouldn't involve
you being so connected to people getting
into debt
well yes
um you know I I'm I'm in Tech now
um so I've considered looking for
another role but the economy is kind of
interesting when it comes to Tech and I
have um I don't know I need the stable
income I've got a little baby at home
and like I said we're trying to crank
out maybe step number two so I'm nervous
to jump ship yeah well I wouldn't
suggest that you jump ship Neil because
I mean I mean obviously what you're
doing is now conflicting morally in what
your convictions are what you're
believing about money so that's a real
thing and I think it's important to
listen to Because if you're in it for a
long period of time naturally that's
just gonna wear
on you and who you are and we don't want
that for anybody in their work right
their line of work but you're not doing
anything illegal right I mean like like
you're so I mean obviously if you came
out here and you're like I'm dealing
drugs so we'd be like all right now we
gotta shift shift careers maybe you
should jump back yeah you're not I mean
you're not doing anything illegal so you
have time to give yourself some patience
to go and but I would be actively
probably looking for someone or
something else again just because
you going into a line of work every day
40 hours a week doing something that
starts just to rub up against you
morally like that's just not a fun place
to be right so again I wouldn't jump
ship right now but I would
um I would be pursuing other stuff and
the great thing is you know with I mean
there are some there are some layoffs
happening in the tech industry uh we're
seeing that a lot but there's also a lot
of places still hiring and and I think
in your line of work there's still
opportunity to be had so
um I would if I were you be actively
proactively looking for something but I
wouldn't just quit tomorrow because I
feel like that that's unwise
yeah
yeah I hear you there I'm gonna send you
Ken Coleman's get clear assessment
because I think it will help you go all
right it really isn't lending that I'm
all about I really love helping people
do XYZ I can go work in the tech space
but not in the finance space or I can go
work for in the finance space but not be
a part of the lending uh section and so
the thing with Banking and Banks make
money from debt products largely and so
anywhere in the fintech space you're
going to have this moral issue and so I
think you also need to go is there
another line of work that I could do
that's connected to the skills that I
have that doesn't connect to the
financial world
yeah yeah I think it's definitely out
there just got to find those
opportunities yeah we're rooting for you
man yeah for sure hang on the line
Austin will pick up and we will make
sure you get that get clear assessment
from our friend Ken Coleman all right
let's move on to Cassie in Huntsville
Alabama Cassie welcome to the show
[Applause]
thanks for taking my call how are y'all
we're doing great how can we help
good
um so I have a situation
um I'm just trying to make sure that I
am doing the right thing here
um so basically my question is should I
sell my house and live in a camper until
my husband and I can save enough money
to pay for and build our home
um so a little background there I know
that like campers they depreciate and um
we would buy one anyways later down the
road uh I am in nursing schools and I
plan to do travel nursing so we're gonna
need one regardless
um but I just I don't know if I'm
jumping the gun here we are on baby step
two we have about 32
000 in debt and we have
just over a hundred thousand in equity
in our home
um so we would use that to pay off our
debt and then just pay for a camper
so how far away are you guys from
actually buying this future house or
building it
[Applause]
I mean that would be it no more debt
whatsoever so we would just work on
saving 250 maybe to build My worry is
that this sets you backwards instead of
forwards because the camper goes down in
value you sell your house which is
appreciating in value and so by the end
of this thing you're actually down
instead of up what if you just stayed in
the house stayed put paid off your
Consumer Debt get through nursing school
and then we can see where we're at
financially yeah Cassie how old are you
guys
uh I'm 22 and my husband is 23. okay and
how much do you guys make a year
uh
we make about 4 800 a month so I think
it's like 15 off maybe yeah
um
yeah I would probably slow down a little
bit I think when you said am I jumping
the gun I I kind of feel like you might
be
um I think that it's a great goal to
have and I think a very realistic one
for you guys in the future but I think
you have a couple of steps ahead of you
before I would jump to selling your home
right now I think
um paying off this Consumer Debt like
George said
um and if you get into travel nursing
too that pays really well and so you'll
be able to even knock out that Consumer
Debt if you still have some going into
that new job
um and so I would focus on all that get
an emergency fund in place
save up a down payment
um or I guess if you guys yeah are
building the construction loan and going
through that whole process but I
wouldn't be in a rush to do it right now
Cassidy I think it's a great five eight
year goal maybe to look out there but I
think you would be rushing some of the
progress uh that could be made and like
George said you could end up actually
financially backwards if you if you do
this so I would stay in the home pay off
the Consumer Debt get an emergency fund
get a great uh getting a great financial
position to get a down payment the
construction loan and go from there I
like that slow is usually the best path
and the most frustrating and so patience
is a virtue for a reason delayed
gratification you guys will get there in
no time you're 22 and 23 you got so much
time ahead of you to hit those financial
goals more of your calls coming up
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back Ed by their
watch and guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
Campbell joined by Rachel Cruz this hour
and we're taking your calls at AAA
825-5225 we're talking about your life
and your money all the stuff that's
ruminating your brain inflation and your
debt payments and what about student
loan forgiveness and this mortgage fees
just is getting out of control in the
housing market and we just want to give
you a breath of fresh air and tell you
the truth even if it hurts a little bit
because we want to see you win with
money Murphy is joining us in Phoenix up
next Murphy welcome to the show
George and Rachel thank you for taking
my call sure how can we help
so uh my wife and I are completely on
board with getting debt free there's a
little contention in regards to some
property that we own and the question is
this we own a condo outright that's
currently worth about 275 000 on the
open market but we have an existing
mortgage as well about 250 000 I'd like
to sell the condo and pay off the
mortgage and she kind of thinks because
the condo has been paid off for that we
just keep ticking along with the
mortgage and I'm just looking for advice
from you guys in regards to that
do you have any Consumer Debt Murphy or
is it just the mortgage
um we we have a car loan yes uh there's
about 30 000 sowed on a car loan okay
how much you guys have in savings
um so that's a little difficult too we
had a hundred and fifty thousand in
savings that we let our son borrow for a
business that he started but he's going
to be paying that back to us here real
soon in less than 30 days as like a lump
sum
uh or yes wow okay so you'll have 150k
in a month
yes now clear the car alone
yep and clear a huge chunk of the
mortgage too yeah outside of leaving a
you know a big chunk for your emergency
fund of three to six months
yes
I mean
honestly Murphy I don't think there's a
right or wrong here I mean it's a pay if
if you guys had a mortgage on the rental
property I would say just sell it but
because you guys own it outright I mean
it's an asset and then at that point you
know we we always say to be intentional
through baby steps one or um four
through seven
and
which means to me you don't I don't feel
like you have to be overly intense and
overly intense would mean selling the
condo and putting it paying off the
mortgage and you're just you're you're
done
um so I don't feel like you guys have to
I think you have some great cash coming
in you're able to hit the mortgage how
much you guys make a year
um so I'm self-employed so that
fluctuates quite a bit a year but like
last year of the combined income was 850
000. 850 oh yeah Murphy y'all just as in
eight five zero zero zero zero
uh eight hundred and fifty thousand yes
that's great your mortgage is gone yeah
within like a few months at this point
okay all right so I think no no Murphy
if you don't sorry George
and you don't want to be if you don't
want to be a landlord though and you
guys aren't happy about investment real
estate and you're like it's a it's a
drain it's not fun we don't want it then
yeah for sure sell it and get out and do
some other investing with your money
because you guys are gonna have plenty
of cash coming in plenty of income
coming in to be able to go and do
whatever you want to do investment-wise
so if it's not something that you guys
want to if you don't want to be a
landlord then yeah sell it but if you
guys love it and you enjoy rental
properties I I would keep it and then
pay off the mortgage with your income
okay yeah that's that's also where we
disagree because I don't necessarily
enjoy it okay
does she who who deals with the property
more you or your wife my wife does my
wife definitely does okay she enjoys it
and she likes it
uh I don't know if she ETS or not you
know anytime there's a repair that's
required she gets involved she takes
care of it she calls repairman stuff
like that she collects the rent from it
she deals with all that okay I don't
think she she has a corporate job as
well so I don't think she necessarily
likes or enjoys it okay so what you know
what I would do Murphy is I you'd say
you can get 275 for it
yep okay I mean I would kind of I would
have a date night we always talk about
doing like a dream date night and take
270 275 on the table and you and her
talk about what could we do with this
money is there better Investments what
if we just put it in the market and do
an investment calculator and just say
what could that grow to in 20 years what
if we found a small business that we
loved and we wanted to get in and you
know be part owners of that and we could
put that there uh do we want to you know
maybe buy a different property do we
want to take this and go and travel the
world like go and just dream with 275
000 and if nothing keeps bubbling up and
saying gosh we have to do this right now
we want to do this and she's fine with
keeping it then maybe keep it but at
least have the discussion of what would
we do with the money if we sold it just
as for the heck of it but if she's
fine with it and it's not a big problem
to her then I mean making 8.50 even if
you regret the decision after selling it
you can go buy another three hundred
thousand dollar property by the end of
the year
so that the intent of the condo was
never to be a positive cash flow income
for for us it never was because the
original intent was as a backup house
because we bought this in the crash of
2008 we only paid uh 38 000 for it um on
a short sale oh wow and the goal the
goal of the property had always been
that hey we have this million dollar
house if we ever lose it because
something happens and I'm self-employed
we have a backup oh I gotcha that was
always the goal and if I can take the
cash from the condo and pay off the
existing mortgage now we have that home
security in our main house so that's
kind of why I'm trying to steer her in
this direction because the goal of the
condo was just housing um security and
why does she want to keep it what's her
reasoning for keeping it I'm not sure
you know what we have a date night
tonight so I will add perfect
that's great yeah and I honestly think
since you can't even answer that
question I think you you guys may come
to a conclusion really quickly you know
she may be like oh perfect that's right
that's true that makes sense if our
homes paid for then there is no risk on
that end with our primary home so we
don't need it you know it could be a
pretty easy discussion yeah but
originally she she and I both agreed
that we wanted to keep it for that
housing security because yeah that was
in 2008 Murphy now I mean that's like I
know 15 years ago and you guys obviously
haven't talked about it recently so I
can't even remember what I said in 2008
you know that was a long time ago so I
would I would have a current discussion
with her and again to George's Point
there's not a right or wrong cure I mean
you guys are in great financial shape
you make great money you don't don't go
into any more Consumer Debt that 30 000
Carlo needs to be paid off today uh save
some money and yeah I think you'll be
okay what's your net what's your net
worth combined
um so the
it varies a little bit but we're kind of
touching that 10 million mark
10 million dollars and we're arguing
over a 250 000 mortgage but but we've
gotten to this point because I've been
really aggressive with tackling
everything and I'm not I'm not where the
finish line is near and I'm not letting
up is is Murphy
you need to chill it's Friday night
tonight I think you just need a you need
to take it you're you guys are doing
great you're an intense guy and I like
it I have an intense dad my husband has
some intensity my old friend George
camel has something we need Rachel's in
our life and it's all good but but
you're fine Murphy y'all are good you're
good we talked to actual broke people on
this show and so talking to you I'm like
what is this guy I need to ask you for
advice man I know help us with our money
market goodness gracious well I'm I'm
rooting for you guys thank you so much
for the call great job aspire to that
y'all are y'all have worked really hard
and done a really great job I know we're
kind of poking fun at you a little bit
but well I mean it's impressive well
it's hard to turn that intensity off for
sure and Winston Cruz was on this show
earlier this week so I feel like chopped
liver compared to everyone loved having
Winston Cruz which is Rachel's Husband
by the way on the show talking about
real estate and how to do it the right I
missed you George he wanted to he really
I'm secretly hoping me and Winston can
do an hour
because I can't hang Winston doesn't
want to hang out with me outside I love
it having to do this whatever George you
came over and watched Dumb and Dumber I
did that was a few months ago at our
house and at Winston learned that when
George had never seen Dumb and Dumber
and Winston was like changed my life
George you need to come over and you
need to watch this movie oh well what
was the big takeaway from having Winston
on earlier this week the big takeaway
yeah on real estate
um did he have any hot takes yeah I mean
he's a great kind of processing with
some of the callers through there I
think I think the biggest thing is
if you're doing it if you're doing
investment real estate while you still
have other risks whether that's a
mortgage on your primary or how many
other things it's it's not worth it in
the long run because usually the cash
flow that comes in from the rental
doesn't really take like a doesn't have
a big weight yeah because of everything
else you have to do with it so if you
think it's kind of this get rich quick
oh if I own this great it's it's a
little bit more difficult than that
that's good good summary thank you for
that you're welcome more of your calls
coming up right here on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by best-selling
author host of The Rachel Cruz show
Rachel Cruz herself here with me today
the number to call is triple eight eight
two five five two two five well Rachel a
lot of people send us stuff on Instagram
and the DMs like things that they think
are funny or that will rile us up and
occasionally enough people send a video
to me that I'm like we gotta put this on
the show it's funny it's worth
everyone's time so I want to play it for
you you've seen this because I saw you
comment on the video yes it's from a
comedian who lives in New York city
named Nathan McIntosh want to give him
credit on this one and it's a hilarious
uh bit on student loans so let's check
that out
how did we ever to lend money in the
first place
through to their name why
there are people with jobs and credit
who can't get loans they walk into banks
with business plans they're like
two-year projection five-year projection
the bank's like get out of here man
it'll never work and then some kid
Waddles it what do you need the horse
literature degree
[Laughter]
so good it's so true though it's funny
because it's true that's what they say
because it's true people come with
business plans and show Roi
so so everything you know and they still
get turned down and they get turned down
but still loan companies will just give
out free money going and you'll be fine
just get your horse literature degree
yeah you know it doesn't matter if you
graduate
we're gonna give you 80 000 that's on
the low end that's right for real oh my
goodness well there's a there's truth to
it and there's also the story behind it
which we cover in borrowed future both
on the podcast and the documentary but
Sally May and uh the government you know
they they co-mingled they're in cahoots
with each other and they said the
government's like hey Sally May we need
more people to get educations so we'll
cover the loans if they can't pay the
government will back it yep and so it
began the federally backed Student Loan
program and student loan companies are
going sweet we're just going to give out
as much money as possible because the
colleges love it they're going to sweet
we'll raise prices we can keep raising
tuition and they still get the money and
they still and it's just this wonderful
cycle that's happening in America today
and it's it's crazy do you feel a
backlash from college though right now
like do you feel people are pushing back
against the idea yeah I think gen Z is
are the ones going this is stupid
because they're seeing their brothers
sisters family still paying off student
loans with student loan forgiveness
dangling out there and they're going
this isn't the path yeah so we're seeing
a lot of gen Z folks who are going I'm
going to turn my side hustle into the
full-time thing and so I respect the
hustle of these younger Generations who
are I know I'm going I'm too smart to
fall for something this stupid because
we're all for higher education I think
it's wise to continue to learn and to
grow but it's when the ROI doesn't play
out
in the marketplace right I mean like I
mean he's joking about horse literature
but like for real like there really are
the most bookstore I feel like there
should be legislation around what
degrees you can even offer I mean
seriously because I'm like because you
can't go into the marketplace with that
degree and make that amount of money if
you go to a private school even not even
like a super fancy one but just even
like a liberal arts even some of these
Christian colleges right that are
private all that I think you're paying
140 getting out I mean like they're so
expensive for a degree that's not going
to make that in the marketplace so yeah
it's
I think yeah people are finally waking
up being like okay what and now granted
if you're
you know a dentist or a doctor I mean
like there are obviously massive uh
degrees to get that will create a
wonderful career path and even a
business degree right I mean yeah there
are still degrees to be had and we have
degrees we can call that out yeah
but then you're still just looking at
the ROI I don't know it's yeah I don't
think the degree is what caused any
level of My Success you know what I mean
the degree itself I know it's great it's
a check mark but more and more employers
even Ramsay Solutions is going do you
have the skills do you have the talents
are you a culture fit did you get the
experience and knowledge from somewhere
and because I think the degree is just
watered down that almost everyone has
one right like when our parents it was
special we're doing it yeah it set you
apart it did and now it's like well
everyone can get one because anyone can
get a loan to the comedian's Point like
you know you anyone can just walk in and
get a loan so yeah it doesn't create
that like oh that weight that it used to
and then us Millennials we were we were
right on that front end of the of the
crisis so yeah I don't know it's an
interesting conversation to have well go
watch borrowed future if you are a
parent if you are a student and you're
curious about this stuff we lay it out
in 88 Minutes flat and it will create
some amazing conversations with you your
kids and get you riled up about this
problem which I think we should be riled
up about and we shouldn't be waiting on
the government to fix it because uh we
could be waiting a few lifetimes
let's get to the phones Luke joins us up
next in Kansas City Luke welcome to the
show
how are you guys we're doing great how
are you doing good so uh calling in
about student loans perfect oh great so
yeah that's perfect right so
um my wife and I we have a combined
about forty seven thousand dollars worth
of student loans
uh thirty seven thousand dollars of that
comes from me and the other 10 000 is
from my wife
um so over the last two and a half years
we've taken advantage of this no
interest here or not having to pay our
loans and we saved up about sixty
thousand dollars
um so we have that to pay it off
um so since we started doing that we've
started investing into our 401K which I
do have follow-up question on that but
the question is you know
I don't want to rely on the government
um and I don't necessarily agree that
they should pay it off but is it worth
going ahead and throwing that money
there and paying those loans off or you
know we've waited this long should we
wait just a little longer to see if it
see if it actually happens or not
Luke you know our answer
I know I was afraid what are you going
to do with that money if you don't pay
off the student loans
well we have the point that we do have
right now is the student loans and our
house payment and we have about a
hundred and ten thousand dollars left on
our mortgage
um so it could go to that uh
but I mean we're at the point now to
where I I started investing by 15 into
my uh 401K Roth and my wife uh I finally
got her talked into doing at least 10
percent she's not 100 on board with
paying the loans off
um I mean she's to the point she's
looking at cars and I'm trying to talk
her out of it so
um
so here here's the thing Luke what we
have found with people with debt
scripture says the borrower is slave to
the lender and whether you believe with
scripture or not it's a saying of wisdom
that when you are in debt and you owe
someone something there is a level of a
there's a lack of Freedom that you just
naturally have and it may not be a
hundred percent financially in your boat
right because you have the money to pay
it off uh but there is something to be
said I think from a mental health
standpoint uh I think from a spiritual
element there is just something when you
know you owe someone something
and when you pay it off and you have the
money Luke so today is what we would say
that when you get off the phone with us
you guys freaking just log into your
account and pay this thing off there is
there is a small weight that you are
carrying even even though you have the
money in the bank there is something to
be said that when you don't owe anyone
anything there is a level of Freedom
that comes a level of levity a level of
peace that you just can't fully have
when someone else's name is attached to
your income and to your life and so from
the financial perspective you know we're
all about getting out of debt because
when you free up your income you can
invest it you can build wealth you can
do so much with your income versus it
going back out to car payments and
credit cards and student loans and all
this but then there's that other element
and Dr John deloney talks about this
from the mental health perspective
that there is again there is something
that happens in the human I think Body
Mind Spirit Soul when you are just free
when when no one else when you're when
you don't owe anything and so I would I
would say
you guys pay this off pay it off today
and if she just just wants to get back
into forty three thousand dollars of
debt again if she's just oh misses debt
if she misses it and you guys want to go
get back in as a couple there are plenty
of ways to go back into debt if you guys
want but I guarantee you when you guys
pay it off and you look forward to your
future and you see money that is saved
you see money that is saved for a car
and you guys cash flow these purchases
there's there's a there's a reason
people don't go back into debt
still have 13k call that your emergency
fund now you can actually invest with
Pure Freedom but you're lying to
yourselves if you think you have sixty
thousand dollars you don't because you
owe the student loan companies 47 right
that's bad math so net worth
is your yeah
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel here with Rachel Cruz this
hour and we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you know it's interesting George is
when you start to change the way you
think about money and you actually start
to win with money those changes spill
over to other areas of your life so
before you know it you know you're not
just out of debt but your mental health
your job your marriage relationships
start getting better and that's what
happens we talk about all those things
at the Smart conference so this is two
action-packed days that you'll leave
with a plan to win with money get free
of anxiety and start knocking out all of
your goals for the future and this is
our biggest event that we do here at
Ramsey solution so you don't want to
miss it this is more than just money
this is about your entire life and so we
really say that this one weekend could
change so much because because there's
so much content around your entire life
so we are actually gonna have the smart
conference this fall in Chicago which we
are so excited about so Chicago Illinois
will be there for the smart conference
weekend
uh in September the 15th and the 16th so
it's Dave Ramsey Dr John deloney George
Campbell Jade warshaw Ken Coleman and
myself we will be in Chicago for the
smart conference weekends and we would
love to see you there you can get early
bird tickets it just start at 79 we've
got VIP level tickets that include a lot
of Swag and opportunities to meet all of
the Ramsay personalities plus we have a
new Platinum package that includes
dinner with Dave and all the Ramsay
personalities so go to
ramseysolutions.com events for tickets
and start to take charge and control
over your life love it and I assume
we'll be getting deep dish at some point
I think that needs to happen and
probably a live smart money happy hour
recording we've been doing that in some
of these and they're so fun and they're
so I can't promise it but we'll push for
it
all right let's go to the phones Cody
joins us up next in Atlanta Georgia Cody
welcome to the show
are you with us Cody uh yes I am can you
hear me yeah how's it going how can we
help
I'm good hey so I had a question as far
as uh collections went
um got a collection bill working on
pretty much paying off all the debt and
that's pretty much the last one I was
seeing I know Dave recommends to a
cashier's check bullet I was saying is
privacy.com okay for something like that
or should I really probably do uh
cashier's check on it
so privacy.com uh where'd you hear about
that
um I've been using it for a bit
um I said I know how it works I was just
seeing you know
yeah well I was curious because we've
talked about it on this show and uh
producer James Charles is a fan too but
uh it's I could see that being a good
tool because you can set limits on it so
that's what you want to look out for is
you don't want to give them just blind
access to your account so you can set a
limit where you say hey this is a
one-time transaction it creates a
virtual debit card based on your actual
debit card so it's a lot safer and you
can set those limits so that would be a
good modern way to do this how much is
the debt that's in collections
uh 725
725 dollars
yeah okay um essentially that's the last
one I have two other medical bills and
then me and my wife have no debt that's
called you and Rachel
um actually a couple of months ago about
uh selling the very nice car that I had
bought and you did it
yes I did and bought another one cast so
that's awesome it's fun to hear the way
are they now stories
we're so shocked honestly we're like no
they're not going to sell the card
nope paid off the student loans too I
don't have those I don't have to worry
about you know good for you awesome and
you have the money to pay off the
collections debt today
and I still have above you know a couple
thousand in a emergency fund nice and
You're Gonna Knock Out those medical
debts
with some of that money yep as soon as
they're done processing yep man that's
awesome good for you Cody we're excited
for you yeah that's great but that's
totally cool if you want to do
privacy.com just make sure you have
those parameters on there uh to set
limits can I be ignorant for a second I
can it's what is it so it's a website
and I use it for like trial subscription
things because you
it creates a virtual debit card so it
has totally different numbers in your
debit card okay that's attached to your
debit card okay and you can set limits
and say hey this is for one transaction
only you can only use this up to a
hundred dollars this only works for the
next 30 days and so you can set a lot of
cool parameters on this virtual debit
card
is it for trials for subscriptions yes
yes or so a site something I don't want
to put my actual debit card information
so it's great for actual data protection
okay fraud things like that because I
can just shut down that card delete it
anytime I want yeah yeah so it's a
really cool tool that people can use
when shopping online for safety yeah so
I would use it across all online
shopping and sure because there's a big
fear out there people go I'm going to
use my credit card Rachel because the
debit card is not safe that's your money
if they do yeah yeah so this card uh
virtually is different you can set all
kinds of different parameters okay so
it's a cool tool not hashtag not
sponsored uh but you know I think it's a
pretty cool that's a good product yeah I
think there's some great that's what's
funny about the financial products out
there there's some that are just
terrible and I feel like we we talk
about those on this show a lot to warn
you all yes and then there's those that
are actually very helpful and useful and
yeah those financial products exist to
sell you debt and this one actually is
for the debit card users out there yeah
keep us safe love it
all right Andrew is in Providence Rhode
Island Andrew welcome to the show
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
how can I help
um so
so I'm 33 years old and my wife and I
um are looking to build our future house
and I hired a real estate professional
got some numbers and I'm a G I'm gcing
the project myself and with all the
numbers that I came up with
um I'm going to be into the house for
that does not include the land I paid
for the land in cash awesome
um but with that being said
um
I can't borrow more than three hundred
thousand dollars to stay within my 25 of
my uh monthly income between me and my
wife
and with the sale of my house at the
bare minimum at 550 000.
um I'm going to be short roughly 125
000.
um the project is going to take roughly
a year to build and in that time I would
be
obviously saving money so my question to
you is do I pull the trigger with
proceeding with building the house
knowing that within the next year I can
save 125 thousand dollars
or do I wait
to save that 125 and then go ahead and
sell my house to stop building my house
I'm just concerned with the real estate
market right now
yeah how much how much do you make
Andrew
between my wife we're roughly 200 225
000 a year and do you guys have a
lifestyle that would support you saving
125 000 in a year
uh yeah so her and I are extremely
Frugal
um we literally we don't do anything we
don't have any car payments don't go out
yeah it's our Dream to build this house
and you know within the last six years
listening to you guys I've paid my house
off in cash and I paid a piece of land
that was worth 225 000 in cash so
awesome that's great so when would you
have to actually have any money do would
you get a construction loan for this
yeah so I would pull out a construction
loan and I'd be borrowing three hundred
thousand dollars
um but I'd be sure based off of the
numbers and the numbers that I came up
with I I fluffed up I have a spreadsheet
and I added a little bit onto each one
just because I know things can change
within a year a construction costs and
whatnot yeah
um and also the sale of my house I went
on the low end at 5 50. my real estate
professional said roughly I could get
anywhere between 550 and 6 on the high
end
fees
uh correct okay correct yeah so I have
to also factor that in I mean I'm I feel
like this is a little bit on the risky
side I might give it some pause until
we're closer to that Finish Line because
right now you're battling what if the
housing market moves and what about if I
don't have the 125 what if our income
changes it just gives me some pause yeah
I mean honestly I would I would feel
comfortable with you guys trying to cash
flow the 125 000
um because my husband and I when we were
building we we were short a little bit
and we just knew within that nine months
what we were gonna make we had locked in
our in common so we knew that but my
only fear honestly Andrew is that it's
contingent on the sale of your home and
with the market being so crazy that
almost makes me more nervous if you guys
could pause for nine months 12 months
and save some cash and have some buffer
I think that would give me more relief
and more peace during the process versus
being so stressed out so I would
probably pause like George said just for
a little bit save some money and and
then proceed but I think you run your
numbers well and yeah
that yeah and also live a little you can
you guys have worked so hard enjoy your
life do go out so create some goals in
all of those areas and you'll get that
dream home in no time this is the Ramsay
show
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell Ramsey personality co-host of
smart money happy hour and I happen to
have the co-host of smart money happy
hour with me Rachel Cruz AAA 825-5225 is
the number to call you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money and
on top of smart money happy hour Rachel
I recently launched my own YouTube
channel that's right so we're both
YouTubers now and it's killing it you've
done such a great job the numbers are
like fantastic well the team that we
have content too is incredible the
editors the designers the writers they
have worked so you're set oh the set is
beautiful it's amazing thank you well
done there's no Rachel Cruise show no it
is nicer than the Rachel Cruise shows
wow and I tip my hat too George I think
it's fantastic well I'll have you on as
a guest oh thank you I really appreciate
it just right down the road it's around
the hall really appreciate that thank
you so go check it out I think we've got
about 10 videos out there and and people
are loving it they're commenting on the
editing the humor we're taking the
Ramsey principles to to 2028 and we are
living in the future we are in the
future so many memes it's a good time go
check that out all right Brandi joins us
up first in Charlottesville Virginia
Brandy welcome to the Ramsay show
hi George hi Rachel hi Rachel for having
me
absolutely how can we help
um so I know Dave says that options are
great
um but right now I can't feel the same
about that
um I have
um three houses right now
um I lost my mom in 2001 and my dad in
um and in that I inherited two houses
plus I have my own here
um
when my mom passed away I became power
of attorney for my grandmother so that
house
um that I inherited from my mom was
actually hers and she had lifetime
living right from there but I had to
move her to a nursing home close to me
so she's no longer in that house and
it's vacant
um
so my question for you guys today is
um should I sell both houses
um or should I sell one house and rent
the other out for like additional income
because I do have a little bit of debt
I've been working on
my smallest to largest I just I don't
know what or how to make a good decision
you know everybody wants to tell you oh
you should do this or you should do that
like I think I know but I have so many
feelings with
um both of these houses that yeah
they're sentimental to you I'm sure yeah
yeah for sure that that plays into this
uh do you do they have mortgages on them
at all
so my dad's house does and that's an
hour away from me my grandmother's house
is six hours away okay so and it's okay
and that one's paid for yeah okay
and Brandi where are you at financially
you said you have some debt how much
Consumer Debt do you have
um
have
a little over
let's face
so I have a boat at 31.
I have my car 6800 so it's about
30 let's just round it up forty thousand
forty thousand okay do you have any
savings any cash in the bank
I do okay um how much do you have
uh let's see I have a high yield at 40
000. okay
um and I have my
um three to six months in that
um and then I have a 15 000 just regular
savings account okay wow and last
question sorry we're Gathering numbers
so I hope you're you're good yeah and
then the two houses how if they sold
today how much would they be worth
so the house six hours away the
assessment is 125 000. okay I don't
really know like what I would put it on
like
what it should go for but around that
okay
and then the other house
um it's assessed at about 250. and how
much is owed on that
92 92 too okay
wow okay well here's the good news you
can pay off your Consumer Debt today
without even worrying about what we're
going to do with these homes
yeah
you've kind of done like baby step three
baby step one then baby step two and
Brandon when you called in I felt the
sense that you were overwhelmed you're
managing a lot right now you've been
through a lot
yes and so if I were in your shoes what
I would want is Simplicity because
there's just freedom and peace in
Simplicity and simplicity means less
payments in fact no payments would be
ideal wouldn't it
yes and so if you paid off your Consumer
Debt you would still have fifteen
thousand dollars in liquid cash
which is about half your emergency fund
so and then listen to this Brandy and
then what I would say Part B to that if
I were you
um which I want to be sensitive because
I can tell in your voice it's it's a
hard topic to talk about but I I would I
would probably I would sell the homes
not probably I would
um do you want to be a landlord because
the one is six hours away and that's
going to be a really that's just uh we
we never ever really recommend being a
long-distance landlord it's not it's
just not feasible uh it adds way more
stress to your life than blessing and so
I would sell that home
um and then I honestly unless you wanted
to be a landlord I would not I would not
keep would not keep your that second
home
um your dad's home either uh to George's
points when you catch all this out
George is writing down the numbers so
forgive me I wasn't but
um when you sell sell all of that you
have money in the bank you're gonna be
able to pay off consumer that you have a
lot of cash available to you Brandy to
be able to invest and possibly even pay
off your current home how much do you
have in your current home how much is
owed
uh 246. okay so I mean you can just this
is I would see this
um
as as a continuation of their legacy
and it's so easy for us to put
sentimental value
in
things right homes or even actual
tangible items um and I and I and I
understand it absolutely but I also
think that this these are becoming more
of a burden to you and more of a
heaviness than a blessing and levity and
so I think a beautiful thing to do for
their legacy
um is that their legacy is not wrapped
up in their homes right that that is
true for anyone right that is here that
that our love and our memories and
things are not our relationships are not
tied to actual things even though things
can symbolize that
that's that they it is still just stuff
and so I think there's a really great
um I think there's great progress that
can be made for you Brandi from a stress
standpoint to I would sell those two
homes I'd pay off your Consumer Debt put
that cash you may have enough I'm
looking at the numbers I think if paid
option you sold both she could clear her
mortgage wow the money she has in the
bank clear her Consumer Debt which means
she could be completely debt free with
no payments in the world I think that's
a beautiful thing Brandy that's what we
would do if we were in your shoes and
you're gonna have to grieve these homes
being sold but either way someone living
in that house you're not gonna like that
either you're gonna go don't that's my
dad that's that's not your house yeah
that's my don't do that and so it's it's
stressful either way but I think there's
less stress and having no payments in
the world so thank you for the call and
trusting us with this question this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ER there's nothing better than having
extra cash on hand just to splurge a
little you know have a little fun so I'm
really excited to announce our Ramsay
cash giveaway is back so this is your
chance to win up to 500 or the three
thousand dollar grand prize so you guys
it's very easy to enter all you have to
do is go to ramseysolutions.com giveaway
and you can enter every day every day to
increase your chances for winning now
there's no purchase necessary and you
must be 18 or older to win and we aren't
stopping there so we actually have an
incredible sale going on and you know I
love a good sale so we are running our
ten dollar sale so you can get the books
and tools that you need to build wealth
find the career that you are made for
improve your mental health and deepen
your relationships the 10 sale even
includes all the questions for humans
cards the conversation cards but from Dr
John baloney and my book know your
yourself know your money and so this is
a great sale make sure that you check it
out and these uh conversation cards are
really fun Dr John galloni did so here's
here's one George uh what's the most
expensive mistake you've ever made oh
that's a fun one well not fun I mean in
hindsight that's right probably I mean
going thirty six thousand dollars into
student loan debt is probably just by
the Numbers the most expensive Financial
mistake you've ever made how about you I
don't know I'm trying to think what we
what have we done that was like that was
so stupid
I know I know because things coming to
my head aren't like the most expensive
but we we've paid way too much for like
Landscaping line like I feel like we've
done things that we were like that you
just overspent on yes yes I'm trying to
think I'm trying to come up with that
you're sick to your stomach I know so if
you guys want to again check out any
books or the conversation cards go to
ramseysolutions.com for the ten dollar
sale make sure to check it out love it
well Rachel the housing market has been
a huge topic of discussion and
Millennials and gen Z are feeling real
defeated right now if you're a renter
out there and you're going I want to own
a home one day and we got this article
that was interesting because we've
talked about home ownership as a part of
your wealth building strategy and USA
Today published this uh headline why it
pays to buy a house homeowners become 40
times wealthier than renters in the past
decade and so it goes on to say uh
low-income homeowners those earning no
greater than 80 of the median income
built 98 900 in well while the middle
income and upper income they accumulated
122 to 150 Grand in wealth so that's a
pretty shocking number that's a big gap
between those low income to high income
homeowners
and it says over a long period of time
home ownership is a solid path towards
Building Wealth and it works in two ways
first you have the advantage of home
price appreciation and second it forces
homeowners to save for monthly mortgage
payments which renters don't have so I
have a lot of this is great for those
that are homeowners yeah they're like
yes this is awesome this is crazy and it
was a huge part of what helped me become
a net worth millionaire is home
appreciation yep we live in one of the
most expensive areas of the nation I
think it's the top 11 County or
something in the country and Home
Ownership that home appreciation really
adds to your net worth and so when
you're sitting out there renting it
hurts to watch all that happen and now
not only are you seeing your friends
become wealthy but you're priced out
that's right so what do you tell people
when they go Rachel I really want to
become a homeowner it feels more
impossible than ever yeah I mean I would
say it is frustrating and I think we're
all feeling that I think and again those
of you that are in the market to buy a
home you're really feeling that
but still at the end of the day
home ownership it is a long-term plan
that is something that you want to be
part of your financial picture uh I
think everyone should that that should
be a goal for everyone but that doesn't
mean you need to go out and buy a home
now if you have tons of debt if you have
no savings that home is going to be a
curse I mean it's going to end up making
You Broker over time and in the present
it's going to be stressful and it's that
is not worth it so getting yourself in a
financial position where it is wise to
then go and purchase the largest
investment you probably will ever make
which is your home uh it's it take take
the time be patient with it even though
I still want that to be part of your
financial picture so be out of debt have
an emergency fund the three to six
months of expenses have a good down
payment I mean if you're a first-time
home buyer you can you know five percent
is the lowest we would say but even if
you can get up to 20 which people kind
of like balk at us saying that but hey
if you can if you can save up a good
down payment that's going to help you in
the long run so again it should be part
of your goal but it needs to be in the
right order and not just go and just
decide I want to be homeowner because we
get calls every week on the show with
someone going Rachel I think I need to
sell my house yes we made it a rash
decision we thought impulsively that
we're wasting money on rent we got to
jump into a house and they realized oh
my gosh home ownership is wildly
expensive yeah absolutely so it's a it's
a great thing and obviously this article
shows it right that it's a it's a great
investment to do it and I know it's
frustrating to feel like you're throwing
money away to rent but if you're broke
and you're looking to pay a check the
last thing you're going to want is a
home is to own a home because everything
then is on you so it just creates a lot
of stress I saw a great quote that said
rent is the most that you'll pay a
mortgage is the least that you'll pay
and it was showing that when you rent
you don't have to worry about all the
other stuff yeah property taxes going up
homeowners insurance going up
maintenance repairs all of those things
that come with home ownership that make
it wildly expensive and so you can't
just compare apples to apples my
mortgage payment versus my rent payment
that's a great Point yep so I I feel for
you all out there and I love the old
Timeless quote the best time to plant a
tree was 30 years ago the next best time
is today and so if that's you you're
going man I wish I could have bought a
house when it was seven thousand dollars
I understand I wish that too and we
bought our house
1942. many houses were you yes so I get
it when the boomers are like I don't
understand I could buy a house on a
part-time job back in my day that's
frustrating Boomer you're not helping
you're not helping when you say things
like that houses are I mean on average
now what 400 Grand
and if you're at a high cost of living
area and then and here's the deal too
wages have not gone up with all of this
either so like there's just a there's a
reality of what we're living in and I
think that we can kind of
not and complain I guess we are we we
can we can be down and out but you do
look back when inflation was high in the
80s like like EV there has been every
generation has felt a downturn
economically and so for us especially
the Millennials whether you're
mid-millennial or early Millennial like
we are this is really our first I mean
the recession was big but for a lot of
us we were in college during that time
we're just entering the workforce and so
for us having families and you know
having careers over a few years this is
the first big hit that we have felt so
it does hurt whether it's inflation the
housing market all of it we feel it but
every other generation is faulted too
yeah because they've had their own too
well looking at the data it was
interesting it was homes in the 1950s
were about two times the average salary
now the average home is six times the
average salary and so to your point
inflation is really hurt while wages
haven't gone up fast enough right it
still is higher than they've ever been I
will say though square footage wise oh
my God smaller home on average so that's
another thing right if you went and
bought a smaller home
how would that be but the average home
in America now square foot square
footage wise is our expectations huge
compared to what they were in the 50s I
looked up my childhood home which my
parents still live in it's a less than a
thousand square feet according according
to the internet I'm like oh my gosh yeah
we have family and you don't remember it
either no you don't remember being that
small we I walked through our childhood
home and and I walked into like the
bathroom that all the kids shared and I
was like and through high school like I
mean like that's like where Denise and I
would get ready for dance I mean like
and it was time how did we survive tiny
and I just thought but I never thought
that I mean like when you're in it so
now it's like it doesn't have a double
vanity so parents out there you're not
harming your children you're not harming
your children yes if you don't have this
massive so here's what that salesman all
that reset your expectations maybe you
get into a small condo or a town home
for now and you don't need a 4 000
square foot home for your first home so
step into it slowly and uh you will get
there and if you are looking to buy a
home you you gotta work with a pro this
is a big one Rachel people make the
mistake of going I could do for sale by
owner I'm not going to use a
professional my Uncle Larry just got his
license do this the right way that's
right and we have an entire network of
Ramsey trusted elps those are Real
Estate Pros in your area who can help
you with this process they sell a whole
bunch of homes they know how to
strategize and get you the best deal and
if you're looking to sell they can help
with that as well and they are marketing
Pros in that Arena so I feel for you
guys out there who are renting but
renting is not a sin you're doing the
right thing and debt is the biggest
thing holding you back from getting that
down payment because when you have
payments up to your eyeballs it's hard
to save up a down payment so get out of
consumer day get the emergency fund do
this the right way even if it's a
five-year Journey instead of a one-year
Journey you'll be okay this is the
Ramsey Show
ha
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsay trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show I'm Ramsay
personality George camel joined by
Rachel Cruz this hour the number to call
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk life and
money John joins us up next in DC John
welcome to the show
hey hey Rachel hey John how are y'all
doing today doing well how can we help
yeah so um I'm 22 years old I just
finished College back about a year ago
in May and I moved up to DC to start
working and I feel like I have quite a
bit of disposable income and I really
wanted to call in to figure out what I
should be doing right I should be
investing or saving up for for a house
in the next few years or
I'm just kind of get some direction for
me all cool so what's your financial
picture look like
um typically uh bases around 110 for my
salary I get a bonus of a few thousand
and employer benefits but they tack on
this stuff from about ten thousand on an
annual basis
um
other than that I usually right now have
about 12 percent of gross pay going into
my Roth 401k about 15 in the company
stock purchase and then about 24 goes to
taxes so after that it's about 49
percent of gross pay I get to take home
cool and you what kind of debt do you
have right now if any
none cool and how much is the total that
you have liquid
in terms of of Stock Investing and um
like yeah non-retirement plus all of
your liquid savings and checking
probably about
between 40 45
awesome and your next goal is to get a
house
I mean ideally you know it definitely
would uh it'd be nice that I know
interest rates are quite high right now
so maybe I was thinking save up even
more and then hopefully things stabilize
in a few years but you know interest
sorry properties ought to get more
expensive so well you're indeed in the
DC area so I imagine you're looking to
pay a pretty penny even for a condo over
there
yeah if anything I'd try to wait and go
back to Virginia or North Carolina where
it's closer to family for me and by
there instead okay so you won't be in DC
for a long period of time for the long
term I would say probably not more than
two or three more years okay
yeah well if that's the case then John I
would not buy something obviously then
um two or three more years as you finish
out your job there or whatever it is
that's keeping you there and then when
you decide I want to settle down in an
area that's when I would probably pull
the trigger in by that point John I mean
you'll have six figures yeah you'll have
some great some great money uh saved up
for a down payment at that point
yeah that's that's kind of the thought
process I've been having yeah so I would
just put I would put that savings on if
I were you since you know it'll probably
be two to three years I I would just do
a high yield savings account yeah and
put the cash there and when it's time
for the down payment to take it out
versus putting it in the market just
because of it being such a short-term
right two to three years of a goal uh
just make sure that you're not putting
the market I'm in the Market's
volatility it's just yeah I mean I don't
know I feel like it's always a little
risky if you know within two to three
years that you're going to be spending
that money yeah well in high yield
savings accounts the rates right now are
so good I'm so jealous like when we were
saving for our house it was at I think
two percent with some bonuses and I was
freaking out that we were getting two
percent on a savings account now you can
get four percent or higher yeah it's
crazy so I would just uh Sock It Away
there make sure you leave your three to
six months emergency fund separate from
the home down payment fund uh so
anything beyond that emergency fund
becomes your down payment and set a goal
for it of hey the house is probably
going to be 700 000 I want to save up
200 thousand you run the numbers stick
to a 15-year fixed that's no more than a
quarter of your after tax income so you
don't include your Investments or health
care and that just after Uncle Sam takes
his cut what would be left over each
month and take a quarter of that
cool I appreciate it y'all thank you
absolutely great job John 22 years old
crushing the game I know well done
wisely done all right Rachel it's time
for our question of the day and it's
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services if you're moving
you've got a long list of to-do's but
neighborly has local Pros like house
Master five star painting window Genie
and Junk King to check items off that
list visit neighborly.com today to
schedule Home Service Experts near you
and today's question comes from Charlene
in Georgia I'm currently on the market
for a new car and new to me car I
stopped by the dealership and told the
salesman the price that I wanted to
spend on a car he quickly figured out
that I was going to pay cash and he
responded that he didn't have anything
in my price range and he wanted to find
it he wanted me to finance at least five
thousand dollars for him to be able to
help me out I declined his offer and
after I left he called me regarding a
car he wanted me to see so I got there
as soon as I could however the car was
so sold just minutes before I got there
I spoke to several of my friends and
they say that the sales rep gets a
bigger commission if you finance a car
they said I will have a hard time at a
dealership and should try a private sale
is this true
well I can tell you anecdotally that it
can be true like they experience
dealerships do make a lot of their money
on financing and they can just refuse to
sell you a car if they're scummy and go
oh you're paying cash never mind or they
go oh you're gonna have to pay an extra
three thousand dollars that price was
for folks who are financing and so not
all dealerships are created equal I will
say that so I would try to find an
independent dealership a used car
dealership versus one of these new car
dealerships yeah uh to try that you
could also go the private sale route and
either way I'm going to do a
pre-purchase inspection it'll cost you
about a hundred bucks go to the mechanic
of your choosing have them look it over
it's worth every penny to know that
you're not about to get screwed and
here's the thing when you go and tell
them they say how you uh how do you plan
on paying today that's always a question
they ask up front to figure out it for
financing
so I don't think it's unethical to just
go I haven't decided yet I don't know
and see how they yeah I really like to
land on out of the door price before we
talk about how I'm going to finance oh
that's good so that's the key the out
the door price is what you're looking
for and once they agree to that then
you're good yeah then you can tell them
all right I'm ready to close the deal
this is it yep but until then it can be
dicey now when we bought our last car uh
Whitney's car
we told him he asked and I was like
we're gonna pay cash he's like okay cool
and then we went through the transaction
and it was the same price that was
advertised online they didn't try to
pull a fast one I don't think I realized
that maybe that's being naive but I feel
like every car that we've bought you
just paid the price I think so that was
listed at yeah yeah I didn't know they
with cash I didn't know that if you're a
cash purchaser they will like jack up
the price lately they've been doing that
with how crazy the car market okay uh
which is not cool but we know that car
dealerships make most of their money for
sure versus the spread on the call of
cash yep yep so it is frustrating out
there but it's not a deal breaker I
would just literally not go to that
dealership and go all right I'm gonna
take my bills business elsewhere that's
right and the key here to George is Cash
yes paying and not a briefcase of cash
because people have tried that and I'm
like no that you don't want to take
twenty thousand dollars in cold hard
we're talking about just money you have
in your bank yes and what's crazy is you
a lot of the times you can use a debit
card if you clear it with your bank
first that there's a large transaction
coming you can also do a cashier's check
or a money order yeah and you can take
that cashier's check and if the price
ends up being a little more you can
cover the difference with cash or your
debit card yep absolutely but it's the
car loan part of our job when we talk to
people that have taken money
oh you know they've taken out a loan to
pay for a car it is one of the more
frustrating debts I think because your
car is going down in value and you're
paying interest on something that is
going down in value so interest rates
are Sky High right now yes yes so you
guys especially used cars where you can
pay cash if you're going to be replacing
your car save up and pay for it it may
not be the most beautiful car in the
world it may not be your favorite car
but at least you're paying cash for it
so it is it's it's so frustrating
because to America it's like it's our
thing we love our cars and it says
something about us we have this like
Pride this dignity in our cars
and I'm like it's it's not worth the
sleepless nights and the living paycheck
to paycheck or where that 700 800 900
car payment every month could be going
for investing and actually letting that
money work for you versus working for
the bank absolutely and people always
come at us Rachel going there's no such
thing as a beater car you can't find a
car under 15 000. yes you can just go to
any car what go to auto trader and then
sort low to high within a 50 mile radius
and I promise you now again they're not
going to be the most beautiful cars no
it's probably going to be 10 15 years
old it might have a hundred thousand
miles but guess what cars can go for
like 300 000 or more to a Honda Civic
Toyota Camry love a Civic love a Camry
I'm here for it Rachel be smart don't go
into debt for a car I know it's a wild
time and you think you deserve that car
but I think you need to earn it and just
drive right now drive like no one else
until you can drive like no one else
that's how it goes this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I'm George camel joined by Rachel Cruz
this hour this is the Ramsey Show open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you've been
listening to this show and you're
confused maybe about some of the lingo
we use we're talking about the baby
steps and gazelle intensity well our
team has created a really great tool so
that you can dive deeper and if you just
go to ramseysolutions.com and hit the
get started button we will help you
figure out the best next step for your
financial Journey based on exactly where
you're at today just go to
ramsaysolutions.com and click on get
started Sandra joins us up next in
Portland Maine Sandra welcome to the
show
hi George hi Rachel thank you so much
for taking my call absolutely how can we
help
well I just wanted to get your advice
um last year my husband and I had to use
some of our emergency fund to purchase a
new car well a new 2s car and
um
we've been
investing and trying to replenish that
emergency fund simultaneously and it's
taking us a little bit longer than we
like so my question is
um in order for the for the process to
go faster we would stop the investing
and and just fully fund the emergency
fund again
but we're nervous doing that uh we're a
little older we're 47 we just started
investing a couple years ago and we
don't want to stop we really enjoy it
um so we just wanted to get your take on
it if you think
it's a big deal stopping for what would
be maybe four months four to five months
um or just trying to do both of them at
the same time
well to answer your questions Sandra no
it is not going to be a big deal if you
guys pause for four to five months and
in fact if you guys had Consumer Debt
there's people your age that we tell to
pause while they pay off debt which
could be a two-year Journey so this is
very you know very short term okay you
you're going to be totally fine uh and I
think it's more
um it's more into your benefit right now
and then for the next 15 years just to
have cash stashed away in an emergency
fund then your retirement right this
moment right so kind of even more of the
present looking at taking care of that
is going to be more beneficial to you to
have cash available if something were to
happen to you guys or your jobs or
health or whatever it may be that you
have that money versus it sitting in a
401k so having some of that emergency
fund is really it's really big that's
why we have it at baby step three so I
would pause uh but also I would be
curious you know since it's just going
to take you guys maybe four months is
there places in your budget that you can
just cut and or maybe earn some extra
income or just do something to do that
quickly because even there's a level of
it's it's just more annoyance of going
to HR and going and having to pause your
retirement you know like the logistics I
just wonder if there's something y'all
can do in the next 30 60 days just to
get it funded really quickly
oh I'm sure I'm sure we could go back to
what we were doing in baby step two
um but as you know that that was very
hard and we can do it and we would if um
well I think that's what's causing y'all
not to have the emergency fund though
Sandra I think that you guys have you're
you're living like you're in baby steps
four or five and six but you're not
there yet and so that intensity still I
would push for that because you're
technically still on baby step three
again not for long uh so even take a
month or two months and do your every
dollar budget and be like okay what if
we pause all of our subscriptions what
if we didn't go out to eat like yeah for
for 60 days what if we just pulled
everything back put all that extra cash
and then we can keep moving on you know
it's it's gonna just be a blip uh but
it's gonna be you guys saying oh man
we're gonna have to be uncomfortable for
60 days yeah and I think here's the
problem is people get comfortable when
they're already investing and they still
have some work to do on the debt or
emergency fund side so the reason I like
pausing the Investments is it will cause
you to move faster because you've got a
fire under you now to get back to
investing because of how much you love
it so yeah I like having something that
is fueling me to keep going I think we
need that as humans for our psyche
otherwise we just love the comfort of
Ghana we're fine we're investing we'll
get the emergency fund when we get there
and then we're frustrated because we're
not where we want to be I mean I'm
curious Sandra are you guys on the more
of the three months or the six month
side that you're wanting to save for
we save on the six month side okay uh so
you guys have what saved now three
months
we have thirteen thousand so yeah I
think that's about half it'll be about
okay so about three months worth
um do you guys have kids what kind of
what kind of careers are you in
um we do have children one is already
out of the house and the other graduates
in a month
um their College is already paid for
um and as far as careers uh we are we're
in the same career we've been in it for
30 years so we're stable in our careers
I mean honestly Sandra you guys could
just be good with three months I'm not
trying to get you out of this you could
just kind of add to it slowly and get
there over time I mean like I don't know
I would just maybe you add a few
thousand dollars more just for some
buffer but I mean we say three to six
months and we say on the three-month
side it's honestly you guys it's people
that have stable incomes uh that you
know may I mean your children are more
grown and gone you don't have like
little ones uh running around that
you're having to pay for daycare and all
of that
um so the more stable your life is is
where you can lean more on that three
months six month is more yeah you have a
you know I I always feel like if you're
a young family with lots of kids if your
income is commission based and it could
go up and down if you're in a field of
work that you know maybe there's job I
don't know it's a little bit more off
yeah I don't know uh you know you would
lean more six months so you guys may be
just okay with the three months Sandra I
think that that what's your household
income
about 130 okay and what's in the nest
egg currently
uh you mean in retirement yes
well we we just started two years ago so
it's not a lot but we have about 20 000
in our Roth
um and
I'm sorry we have about 20 000 and that
includes our roths and my husband 401K
that's great cool and you're gonna still
I mean you guys are still young so
you've got another what 15 20 years of
career
to keep investing and keep moving you're
going to pay off the house and be able
to invest even more then and do catch-up
contributions
yeah yeah that's the plan so I would map
it out thank you so much yeah I would
look towards that future and you can use
our investment calculator at
ramseysolutions.com get with a
smartvester pro on our website in your
area uh financial advisor who can walk
you through this and give you some peace
because right now it just feels like we
haven't been investing and we're not
gonna be able to retire versus just
putting it all on paper and going if we
just stay this path and follow these
baby steps what will happen yeah and my
guess is you're going to be baby steps
millionaires you'll be fine and you'll
be fine in retirement with a paid for
house and probably a million bucks in in
the bank that makes me feel good great
job Sandra you're doing great should we
try to take a quick one here Rachel all
right Tommy let's get to them in
Hartford Connecticut what's going on
all right I'll be quick for you uh so
here's a little low down my wife and I
make a household income of about 340
000.
um we just got married about three
months ago and we're looking to crash
our first home awesome that again
congratulations
oh thank you thank you
um so my question would be would you
recommend buying a house for about 525
000 but we need some cosmetic updates
and like some painting and just some uh
some other minor tweaks or would you
recommend going into uh paying a little
bit more like 625 for a more move-in
ready house that's more prepared for
like a family
um I guess my question would be like
what would you suggest doing and what
would be more valuable uh to resell in
about seven to ten years if we decided
to maybe upgrade a home
well that's very dependent on the area
specifically of those houses how much do
you guys have saved currently in the
same area same area okay what so your
income is 340 how much do you guys have
saved currently for the down payment
uh we have Israel about a hundred
thousand okay so my guess is if you're
gonna do a 15-year fixed which is the
only one I'd recommend where the
payments no more than 25 of after tax
income how much down payment would you
need
on let's say that fixer up you need
roughly like roughly 85 to 90 probably
down payment
um oh I was down payment so probably
like 140. okay so we're 40 Grand away
from the uh the cheaper house and then
how much more to get the uh moving ready
house
that'd be about 170 most likely okay so
there's the Gap to me is what what's the
time difference between the two and
which one do we want more and are we
willing to wait to save up the higher
amount
okay I don't think there's a right or
wrong here Rachel no I don't yeah I
think it's whatever you guys want
um it has a difference with a few months
making three yeah and honestly if it I
mean usually your newer homes there's
less to do less maintenance from a
traditional sense more yeah so I would
almost lean that if it's just a 30 000
difference for you guys to save but I
like that railing but I think whatever I
mean maybe the old house has character
and you guys love that look and it's a
preference yeah but make sure you do it
with those parameters and you'll be all
right thanks so much for the call that
puts this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books
[Music]
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsaysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create amazing relationships
I'm George Campbell joined by Rachel
Cruz this hour the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you hop in we'll talk about your
life and your money and if you're
listening to this show I'm going to make
a wild assumption that you hopefully
enjoy it and if you do let me remind you
that this show is no cost to you and so
here's the only thing we would ask of
you that's also free hit the like button
wherever you're hanging out consider
subscribing hit that button as well or
follow if you're on Spotify and leave a
review on the platform that you're
listening on and let us know what you
think of the show and share with a
friend a lot of the times people say oh
yeah a friend told me to list listen to
it they sent me this episode they sent
me this call or this YouTube clip and it
got me on board and now I listen for
motivation so appreciate you all doing
that it helps us spread this message and
spread the hope and impact we try to
make every day
all right let's go to the phone lines
Hayden is in Salt Lake City to kick us
off Hayden welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me absolutely
what's going on
uh yeah I just have a question uh last
year I was on babyset Two And I just had
a feeling that with all the tech layoffs
and everything that were happening and
and the market so I had stopped doubling
down on debt and I went to an emergency
fund I I built that emergency fund up to
six months now with some of the federal
income that we have and I just want to
know if I should continue to pad that up
with inflation being crazy or if I
should go back into into diving into
debt or even putting in some money into
my Roth or my my future Investments how
much debt do you have
I currently have 75 000 in consumer all
right and what's in the emergency fund
or thirty thousand okay and that's all
the liquid cash you have currently
okay
so
number one we're doing the baby steps
out of order and so I would encourage
you to stick the plan and right now
you're making this decision it sounds
like based on fears which some are
legitimate right there could be layoffs
in the in the tech space
correct How likely is that to happen for
you savings
I I don't I don't really know that's the
that's the scary part of it have there
been layoffs at your company
uh there was there was one round uh but
I made it through that and I just not
not sure if there will be another okay
what kind of Consumer Debt is this
I just have a truck and a travel trailer
uh my family both of my children are
under school age and I was in the
military for 10 years so my wife and I
we we traveled when we met in Europe and
something we wanted to continue to do
with our kids before they went into
school and it's just an affordable way
because I can work from the road
and so that's that's why we went through
and decided to get a travel trailer and
a truck to pull that oh and you got a
loan on both of them
correct okay are you still traveling
right now
uh yes we we travel probably two weeks
out of every month especially during the
summer time when the weather's good okay
what's the household income
household income we are grossing about
200k and I met about 170.
okay so how quickly could we pay off
this Consumer Debt
I I think if I if I stopped patting it
my my emergency savings I could have
that RV paid off by the end of the year
and then the truck probably paid off
shortly after that my wife's in grad
school and by the end of next year
she'll be making anywhere between 90 to
100 000 and then we just want to take
all of her income and toss it towards
all the remaining of our debt and I just
yeah my big question is with inflation
everything else do I pad up my savings
my emergency fund a little bit more just
to make sure that we're recovered for
six months or do I just say hey no more
savings and let's just start tossing
this everything we have at that
yeah Hayden you may not you may not like
our answer because we we really do go
back to the baby steps because it's just
the proven plan that has worked and we
have found that when you don't have debt
not only financially are you freed up
but so many other places of your life
you are freed up and so uh what I would
do if I were you I mean according yet to
the baby steps I would take I would take
all of your savings and I would throw it
at the at the truck as the truck the
what's the what do you owe on the truck
I was 51 on a truck and 23 on the Travel
Trailer okay I would pay off the travel
trailer today I would take that savings
and pay it off and then I would work
with yeah your wife to to say okay what
can we do to get this 51 paid off and
then start going back to your emergency
funds and I understand
um
the fear of hey if something were to
happen but do you think just let's just
paint a worst case scenario let's say
you did you say you were laid off okay
how quickly do you think you are
marketable to go get another job
I think pretty quick and yeah I don't
know if my Situation's unique because I
since I was in the military I do get a
VA disability and I know you guys are
big on don't count on the government
don't count on those paychecks and I
don't want to do that either I don't
know what those people in DC are going
to do my wife is using my GI benefits to
go to grad school so she gets like a two
thousand dollar a month stipend that's
great and then I I get my via disability
and the VA disability covers 100 of our
Consumer Debt and our mortgage and so if
that went away like if my if I got laid
off and that went away I would still
have that VA disability and my wife's
monthly stipend from school so you all
are going to be able to survive without
dipping into the emergency fund okay so
then that's another reason why I'm like
so confident to say to use the savings
to pay it off um to pay off your
Consumer Debt because you guys are good
you have so much padding around you with
all of that that I would focus Hayden
completely on this because what's
amazing to think about that if you guys
paid all this off and then your wife
goes and makes another 100 Grand and you
you guys are bringing in I mean you know
close to 300 Grand you guys are gonna be
able to get a emergency fund so fast
you're gonna be able to invest so
quickly and you guys may even say look
up like hey let's upgrade the trailer
you know that and and get something
nicer you know like you there's just so
many possibilities that happen but not
having payments is going to help you get
there faster so we are all about
following those baby steps because they
work so Hayden if I were you I would pay
off the trailer today
um again teaching that going all the way
down to that thousand dollar emergency
fund and you guys attacking the truck
after that and then what's the payment
on the trailer
uh currently the payment's only 250 and
I've been putting 350 a month on it
since we we purchased it last year so
I've been always paying a little bit
more on on the RV and on the truck as
well I just okay are you investing at
all right now
uh no I backed off all my investments
the only well actually the only
investment I have is the new HSA my
son's got some medical conditions he was
born very early so we just want to make
sure we have something good over there
in HSA we have probably about ten
thousand dollars well we have eleven
thousand dollars sitting there now so
we'll cover out of pocket for the year
if we needed to good uh with insurance
and what's encouraging Hayden if you
guys paid that off today you'd have 350
000 extra a month to throw towards the
truck on top of the truck payment you're
making too and 350. add that up and so
here's what I'm seeing Hayden just based
on the numbers you could have only 45
000 left in debt if you use 29 of your
30 savings towards the debt making 200
000 you with a freed up payment you're
going to pay off that 45 within six
months max if you go hard at this thing
then we build back up the emergency fund
then you have true safety right now you
have the illusion of safety and so if
you have this kind of scarcity mindset
where like it all could come crashing
down well if that's the case then having
no payments is the truest form of
security and so you're going to get
there with this income your wife's going
to finish grad school and have that
great income you guys are gonna be back
to a great financial spot but
temporarily it's going to be scary but
we were rooting for you man this is the
Ramsay show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Rachel Cruz who is
also my co-host on Smart money happy
hour so if you're looking for some fun
some levity some entertainment with a
healthy dose of financial teaching kind
of it's kind of a do it all yeah a
spoonful of medicine a spoonful of sugar
makes the medicine go down like that's
what smart money happy hour is that's
what it feels like and people are loving
it kids listen to it they're like I
listen my 10 year old loves it and then
people are like I'm 75 and I love
listening to you guys so something for
everyone with smart money we're all
there we're here so check it out this
weekend you can binge all the episodes
that are out there every Thursday all
right Claire joins us up next in Seattle
Washington Claire welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me absolutely
what's going on
so I'm turning 18 years old this year
and I really really want to learn more
about investing and where to start
um I work as much as I can with school I
have some money in my checking account
the money in my savings account but I've
heard so many different options about
you know investing in Iran Ira doing
real estate all of this but I'm just
turning 18 and I really want to know
what you guys recommend for young people
looking to start investing that is
awesome way to go well done so you're
graduating soon
I'll graduate in a year I'm going into
my senior year this year okay and what
are you doing for work
I work at a small Cooperative in my kind
of small town it's like an agriculture
store almost okay and what do you make
there
a little over 16.50 an hour
cool
and how many hours are you working
it's
it's fluctuates each week
between 16
. awesome way to go and is your GPA
solid
yes 4.0 there it is you're amazing she
just proved because I was just thinking
in my head Rachel you know people who
work 15 to 20 hours while in college
have a higher GPA that's right than
those who don't and there we go and you
proved it okay so you are a rock star
number one do you have any debt
I do not no and how much do you have in
checking and savings
way to go gosh you're doing so well okay
so I would set aside a little bit of
that for kind of a starter emergency
fund for you obviously you don't have a
ton of expenses now are you living on
campus or on your own
I lit I still live at home I'm enrolled
in a local community college so I live
at home and it covers my tuition so I am
still at home not paying anything for
that that is awesome great job okay so
let's talk about investing
I think the Roth IRA is your best bet
right now
okay invest into that in a good growth
stock mutual fund you can diversify it
across the four types that we talk about
we have a great investing guide on our
website I'll make sure Austin gets you a
link over to that that can help kind of
unpack this at a deeper level than we
can do on radio but I think trying to I
don't know that you would Max it out
with the income that you have but
getting to that Roth IRA and
consistently putting money away is going
to be your best bet at 18.
okay
I don't think you need to worry about
all the other stuff and all the noise
you're hearing you can stick to a Roth
IRA once you start your career yeah
you'll probably have an option for a
Roth 401k and that's another great place
and start doing 15 at that point yeah
once you graduate Claire I mean having
some cash on hands between graduation
and entering the real world and career
it's always good just to have some
because you may be moving who knows what
kind of you know if you take a job it
could be deposits you might need to get
yeah in a car upgrade that's right Fair
maintenance just kind of having some
cash for that transition just thinking
through that and then once you kind of
get settled which I have a feeling
you'll probably settle pretty quickly
because I think you know what you want
in live you're very you're very
proactive so once you yeah have that
first job and you're settled in to where
you are and got your first apartment
whatever it is and you're renting uh
that's when yeah the 401K would I would
look into something like that but for
now I'm with George I think having cash
on hands and looking at a Roth IRA I
think is gonna be your best bet yeah and
if you want to help setting that Ross
Ira up you can get connected with one of
our smartvester Pros which they don't
work for Ramsay but they are vetted and
investing professionals that we trust
and if you go to ramseysolutions.com
click on trusted Pros you can connect
with one in the Seattle area and they'll
get you started there way to go awesome
let's go on to Brandon in Dallas Brandon
welcome to the show
hello can you guys hear me you sound
great yes
awesome hey I have a question
um my wife and I have gotten ourselves
in a in a really bad spot uh so we have
about 250 000 in Consumer Debt that's
credit cards and personal loans
um
we're just not sure what to do we don't
have enough income to pay all of our
minimum payments and so we're not sure
if we should file bankruptcy or to stop
paying until we can afford to settle or
we're just not sure where to go from
here
hmm what caused y'all to go 250 000 in
credit cards and personal loans
well it's everything you guys say not to
do
um we decided I decided I should say to
to flip a house and then buy two more
houses with uh a lot of Leverage right
when interest rates went up and we ended
up taking a a really big bath on these
three properties we lost money on all
three of them I'm so sorry
um yeah it's uh it's definitely been
tough and uh and on top of that during
that time I was so focused on that that
I'm in real estate in my production uh
pretty much went to zero during that
time because my mind was just so wrapped
up in that
um
so that that's where we're at and uh
we're just really not sure where to go
from here how old are you guys
uh I'm 28 my wife is 27 we have a
two-year-old daughter and we have
another that's going to be arriving in
October oh my gosh
you know it's wild Brandon uh if you're
familiar with our my family's story that
little baby that's gonna be born that
was me and my sister was two years old
when my parents filed for bankruptcy
um and through real estate issues I mean
Dad did exactly what you did but on a
massive scale and they called all of his
notes and
he uh if he was sitting here today I
think his empathy would be at the
highest level because he was literally
you
um 35 years ago which is pretty wild so
um I I have such like a heart for those
kids and your kids and your wife and all
of it because I know you guys are under
a lot of stress and I know there's
probably a lot of yeah shame and
embarrassment and you feel a lot of the
weights
um
and so I hear I hear all of that so my
question would be how much how much did
you make when you were in real estate
and in your head was not all over the
place with these other rentals and you
were so focused on it what were you
bringing in
so I mean I would average probably
somewhere between nine and ten thousand
dollars a month uh my wife also works
she brings in about five to six thousand
dollars a month
okay and what is the case today what's
kind of the average month for you guys
so so right now she is still bringing
that five to six thousand a month
um I've just rededicated myself to real
estate
um as of last week so right now it's
it's nothing
um you know ideally in the next
if I'm realistic maybe 90 to 120 days
we're going to start seeing some fruit
from all the work I'm doing today okay
yeah Brenda I don't think you're not
you're not bankrupt
um but I would say catching up on those
minimum payments is your number one goal
and Brandon I I in your future here for
the next
probably two to three years you're going
to be doing more than just real estate I
mean you're gonna be doing side hustles
at night you're gonna be exhausted
you're gonna be exhausted because the
amount of effort that you guys are gonna
put into this because I believe you can
to get out of this hole it's going to
take a lot and you're going to be really
uncomfortable
and you're gonna it's gonna feel like a
sacrifice because that's what's that's
what it's gonna take to get out of this
and you guys have to I was gonna say
promise US I mean more promise
yourselves that you align in the sand is
drawn and for your kids sake you will
never ever go back to this again
that debt is off the table 100 because
if you keep dabbling it and Brandon I'm
telling you you're gonna go right you're
going to look up again you're gonna be
right back in this position so you guys
need a mindset shift to you and your
wife and draw a black and white line and
say never again we're not doing this
yeah and for the next three years our
our lives are gonna look a whole lot
different and it's going to be really
hard with those babies at home but
Brandon you're going to be able to do
this you guys are going to be able to to
get out of this but it's gonna take a
lot of work and a lot of sacrificing
your lifestyle for it to put every penny
possible to go towards this dead yeah
Brandon you said it was 250 total
yeah but I I do have kind of a wrench to
throw in it so
um I guess two questions number one is
total debt payments we have around 6 000
on top of uh living expenses of around
nine thousand
um so number one it's we're just not
sure like how do we actually cash flow
this thing like what do we let go okay
here's what I want to do Brandon I'm
gonna gift you guys Financial Peace
University and every dollar premium to
get on a plan but looking at the math on
this it's just a math equation can we
throw Seven Grand a month and be done in
36 months it comes down to something
that simple hang on the line we'll get
you those resources
[Music]
thank you
well if you haven't heard we are doing
something around here that we've never
done before so right now all of the
Ramsay personalities are leading a
Financial Peace University class
including myself and George camel we are
all doing it so we want you to join our
virtual Financial Peace University class
we are so excited about this because
you're going to learn how to handle
money how to pay off debt how to build
wealth all of it and we are going to be
your personal cheerleaders in the class
plus you are going to be in a community
of thousands of others who are going to
do this class with you so we are so
excited about this because we know what
this class does we know the lessons that
are in it the content that is in it will
help you understand how to handle money
and truly change your life you're going
to be in a different place with money
from when you started to when you're
done so my class actually starts this
Monday coming up so you got a couple of
days to sign up so go to fpu.com
that's fpu.com and and my class
my class is gonna be so fun so you
should come and join my class Georgia
food was thrown right shorts George's
class later in the summer I think it'll
be fun too but mine's during a lunch
break I think yours is too later in the
summer so Rachel's is Mondays and
Wednesdays at 1pm Eastern time 12 p.m
central time and that starts Monday and
what's cool is there's nine lessons
normally it's nine weeks we're crunching
one p it is yeah you're right sorry
George you know my time zone I was like
Adventure Time Eastern time I know I'm
terrible at that okay but it's gonna be
so fun it's great so we're gonna meet
let's see four or five weeks twice a
week to cover all nine lessons so it's
we're Contracting it down to make it uh
more palatable for those who want to get
through it this is kind of a boot camp
version with us as your coordinators and
mine starts June 20th so if you want to
start later on in the summer mine will
be Tuesdays and Thursdays you don't need
to start later you need to start on
Monday if you're ready to go I'm gonna
say if you're ready to go through FPU do
not wait for me Rachel's gonna be
fantastic my class will be taped so you
can re-watch if you need to if you can't
do that time or Jade warshaw is doing a
later time during my dates as well yeah
hers starts on Monday as well so if
you're ready to go and just you can go
on fpu.com you can see all the different
classes the different times do what
works for you and to your spouse if if
you can bring them along but it's pretty
excited about this I know I think it'll
be really fun and we've got thousands of
coordinators all across the country that
have been leading classes and so we're
like how cool would it be if we all led
a class uh during the summer time which
is traditionally a time when people may
be you know putting hitting the snooze
button going on vacation overspending
yeah and we want to get you on a proven
plan it's the same thing I went through
10 years ago that helped me go from
broke to millionaire when I first
started at Ramsey and it is incredible
and I'm not just saying that because we
are in the lessons as well now which is
really cool but it's seriously
life-changing content the accountability
when you have to show up every week it
really helps you actually follow through
with this so highly recommend it fpu.com
go sign up this weekend
all right let's go to the phones triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number to call Isaac joins us in
San Diego up next Isaac welcome to the
show
hi Rachel hi George it's a pleasure to
be here and a huge fan of uh tomorrow
morning happy hour oh thank you thanks
man how can we help of course
um so just a quick question uh I found
out me and my wife we both put 15
towards our tsbo retirement my question
is I found out that the five percent
match that we get apparently only goes
towards traditional so my question would
be the 15 that we're putting in do we
continue to put 15 all in Roth or do we
switch it between half traditional half
Roth or all traditional now knowing that
that five percent is locked in
traditional
I would continue on with the Roth under
15 percent
okay it's normal that that's a legal
thing with the IRS where the match has
to be on the traditional side and it's
not an issue all that means is that five
percent portion when you go to retire
you will have to pay taxes on that when
you withdraw it
but it actually creates a really it's
actually uh from a long-term you know
financial planning standpoint it's good
to have different buckets with different
tax implications
because you might go hey we want to tap
into the tax free money first based on
our brackets and income and taxes and
then we're going to tap into the
traditional side later so it actually
allows you more flexibility in
retirement when you have different
buckets you can pull from
all right well easy easy answer I
appreciate your help absolutely great
question way to go both investing 15
into those Thrift Savings plans so good
so Thrifty all right let's move on to
Erica all the way in Anchorage Alaska
Erica welcome to the show
you guys so much for taking my call I'm
a little nervous right now
we're here Rachel and George
hey good job Eric awesome well done
thank you it hasn't sunk in yet so I
feel like by the end of this month when
we don't have next month's payment I'm
gonna be like oh wow there's no mortgage
payment there so great keep that that's
awesome so we had a 30 000 emergency
fund because I wanted basically it
covered like a whole year of expenses so
now without that mortgage payment my
husband and I are discussing pulling 10
000 from that savings now that it's
offset without that mortgage payment and
starting to do a little investing and I
wanted to hear your thoughts on that is
that smart or
not well have you been doing any
investing up until now
play around investing into whatever we
decide online how much you guys make a
year
uh about 150 okay
do you feel like from a lifestyle
perspective you guys are and I know
it'll probably change with the office
mortgage payment but
are you guys enjoying your lives because
investing 30 of your income and then
after taxes and giving and all that to
you are you guys happy with your
lifestyle
yeah I mean I I set up a bunch of
different accounts so we're like saving
for future things
um and then we're going on a trip this
month so I feel like we aren't
like inhibiting anything with our life
good good so yeah we're not we're not
struggling with paint you know all of
that but this is kind of just like
taking that leap of pulling that much
money to do that which kind of scares me
a little bit but my husband's like let's
do it we can make a lot of money
and how is he planning on making a lot
of money with this ten thousand
mine
oh it's going to start operating
so we want to buy into that where the
price is really low right now
um and with the up and operating it's
going to increase
okay did you say a mine where
yeah it's a graphite mine
okay I'm not
and if you guys done your research I
know I I'm very ignorant when it comes
to Minds I know that's probably shocking
but uh have you done like research have
you seen a pretty consistent pattern
with people that have done this like
does it feel like a risky investment or
is this like a shoe and like oh no
everyone in Alaska knows that this is
like a great easy place to put your
money I think yeah I think I mean I feel
like it's safe but it's just taking that
much money from savings to throw into
this well you guys I'm kind of like yeah
well you all have enough in your
emergency fund though minus the ten
thousand right like yeah you you're
playing you have a paid for it house
Erica you're fine just think about this
if would you emotionally even though it
would hurt be okay financially if this
ten thousand dollars was burned in a bag
and you could never get it back again
would you be okay financially yes but
obviously that's so we don't want that
scary but yes and we don't want that but
but you guys have a paid for house I
mean you're in a place that you I mean
yeah take it I just don't I don't want
to put my own hard-earned money in
something until I know like oh yeah
there's for sure a pretty much
guaranteed uh over the long term it will
appreciate appreciate so again if Minds
do that and you know yeah this is a this
feels not like a crazy risky investment
then I would feel comfortable but again
even if I'll say this even if it was a
risky investment you guys can take the
hit you know even if it went under I
just wouldn't want my money going to
something what's your net worth
uh we're close to half a million right
now okay so the key is you don't want
these kind of fun play money Investments
to take up a lot of your net worth and
right now it's not a huge amount but
maybe it cut back though we're gonna do
five grand in the mine and five grand
into a taxable brokerage with mutual
funds and we hedge our bets there that
feels safe yeah but I don't know
anything about mine so I don't know what
to tell you I don't know did he see an
Instagram ad for this I guess there's a
lot more questions to ask but we'll save
those for another time thanks for the
call way to go on baby step seven paying
off the home it's an amazing
accomplishment this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day comes from
Proverbs 25 2 it is the glory of God to
conceal things but the Glory of Kings is
to search things out
Walt Disney once said when you're
curious you find lots of interesting
things
reminds me of the old Ted lasso quote be
curious not judgmental there you go
now uh if you guys if you're not attuned
to the Ramsey newsletter you got to get
on board this thing's completely free
and we are talking about budgeting in
this one coming out on Sunday and if you
don't know budget is a great start to
meeting your money goals and as you
probably figured out making a plan is
one thing sticking to it whole another
animal so we've put together our best
easy to follow tips to help you not just
have a budget but have a successful one
so go sign up for the Ramsey newsletter
at ramseysolutions.com newsletter and
you'll be inspired with these 15
practical budget tips on Sunday open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Kevin is up next in
Houston Kevin welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me
um how you guys doing we are doing great
what's going on
um so as of a couple of hours ago I just
completed baby step two and three in a
matter of quick so the bad investment
property wow Kevin congrats
how did that feel yeah thankfully from
the sale had enough to finish off
student loans and uh fully fund the
about five months of an emergency fund
oh my gosh Kevin Well Done big day
that's exciting thank you it's a great
Friday
so the question is I had been I mean the
house sale's been a little bit in the
meeting but
I've been thinking about like really
trying to give back after all this my
dad actually helped me a lot with his
investment property and through some of
the Pains of it
and so the question is more about like
kind of how much to start giving back
and whether or not it's too much like I
was considering trying to do like even
just honestly this month doing like a
thousand dollar donation to
um kind of a church organization that
he's really active in um kind of in my
mom's name
is her stuff we're starting to give back
but I don't know if that feels like
too much right off the bat or I don't
know it it's weird to balance
um suddenly having extra income yeah for
sure so how much uh do you make a month
um
per month I make around right now 4400 a
month after taxes
um but that's going to go down once I
increase my retirement contributions
okay
and how much do you have you said you
have five months of the emergency fund
do you have any other savings or is that
is that it
um just the thousand dollars that's
there right now okay yeah that's great
um I mean there's no real parameter for
giving
I'm wondering could you do it monthly
and just have a regular donation you
make
[Music]
um
feels different for me but I mean I
guess in the long run it's still money
going to the organization right
yeah I mean I think honestly I'm like if
you if you feel like I really do want to
give this money and you're able not to
get behind on bills like you know
scripture says that to take care of your
own household first and so there is
something to be said about the wisdom of
making sure you're not well you know
you're gonna be able to pay your light
bill and stuff right I mean like your
basic needs and Necessities are covered
in a few a thousand dollar extra margin
this month you're like I want to do it
then yeah then do it but I would I would
also to George's Point there's a a
habitual
um action to be taken a habit to be
produced when it comes to giving and
that's and that's really the that's the
Heart Change where this becomes a part
of your Rhythm every month that you give
something to somewhere so if you want to
give a lump sum this month to this
organization in your mom's name for a
thousand dollars and you're you know
it's not going to put you financially in
a hardship then yeah if you feel a lot
to do that then I mean I would Kevin I
think that's great and then I would look
at next month to George's Point say okay
let's say um you you know I go down to
four thousand dollars a month I want to
give 400 10 of that so 400 a month I'm
gonna practice giving is that going to
be to an individual is that going to be
to an organization is that going to be a
tithe to my church how do I want to use
that 400 but letting it be a habit but
that's part of what you do because we
always want people to be giving saving
and spending consistently throughout the
month uh regardless of really where you
are in the baby steps so that giving is
a really crucial piece to winning with
money long term uh because it just
changes you I mean it really does
there's a heart change that occurs when
you are someone that gives and lives
with that open hand and money can easily
become a
quote-unquote God in your life it can be
a level of oh gosh if I can just make
this income everything will be fine a
lot of value is placed in it there's
just a lot there and when you give it
kind of puts all that in check where
you're like okay I'm I'm I'm actually
letting some leave my hands and I'm not
just hoarding it so it does something to
your heart too Kevin so that consistent
giving like George was saying every
month I we are fans of and the fact that
you're even asking this question tells
me that you are a generous person and
you will continue to be especially now
that you're out of debt Rachel you said
give a little until you can give a lot
yeah and when you're out of debt you can
give more yeah which is an awesome
absolutely yeah love it love the
question all right let's wrap up with
Brian in Los Angeles Brian welcome to
the show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
going on right my question is my mother
uh gifted me my sister's car but my
sister wants me to pay a hundred dollars
a month to my mom to pay her what
um yeah and it's like 10 grand so she
gifted you a car loan
what is your sister driving yeah
she's she has her own car like Alexis
I'm just driving her old car so why are
you now obligated to pay your sister's
car loan
that I don't know we we I thought it was
just gonna be a gift and just pay a
hundred bucks a month but so what
happened with your sister's car so she
was she paying the payments on this
um that car no that car is fully paid
off she got into an accident with her
previous car got and then Pig got this
car paid off and then they gifted it to
me since she bought a new car and
they're not even using this car
there's no debt on the car and she wants
you to pay there's no debt but it's not
her car anymore it's not her car
yeah so I don't know if I should just
it's under my name too so I don't know
if I should return it sell it and get a
new car and what is the legal obligation
to her at this point
the car's paid off your name's on the
title she has nothing to do with this
car
is she angry because she wasn't gifted
why was your why did your mom give her
your sister's car away to her why didn't
your sister just give you a car
uh
there's a lot going on here
um I guess my mom wanted to put it under
my name so let's say if I get into an
accident they can't sue or go through
the insurance to get into my mother's
house if I were to get sued in that case
again I'm a safe driver but are you on
your own insurance
yes okay I pay my insurance now so
you're on your own insurance you're not
on your parents insurance
yes and sister's upset because she paid
off the car and then you got it for free
yes that's really where the rub is it's
emotional for her she's like wait how
come he just gets it for free and I had
to work to pay that thing off
right does she have a new car loan now
she has a new car with a new with a car
loan
with a car loan yes so she wants you to
pay to basically pay her car loan off
because it's not fair that you got it
for free
that's what it sounds like yes okay
that's a classic bitter sibling right
there that's classic Behavior well the
truth is you have no obligation to pay
her and I wouldn't and if she wants to
like destroy this relationship over this
that's on her and it's not on you you
had nothing to do with this your mother
gifted this to you out of her own
volition yes
okay right okay yeah and uh is this does
this shock you about your sister is
there like a pattern of like oh yeah
that makes sense or is this like so out
of the blue of like I cannot believe
she's making me do this this is not like
her
it makes sense and it upsets me but I
just have such a good relationship with
my mom it's just my mom's like the
mediator between us like I don't really
have conversations with myself no I'll
give you this Brian this is a 180
therapy ready for this don't triangle
people so your mom needs to get out of
it it's between you and your sister okay
or between your sister and your mom you
y'all don't need to be triangling this
relationship there's a free therapy Dr
John deloney I'm sure it would back me
up on that good stuff Rachel what a
conundrum and a nightmare of a situation
oh my goodness well that puts this hour
of the Ramsey Show in the books my
thanks to all the guys and gals in the
booth keeping us afloat today to my
wonderful co-host Rachel Cruz and to you
America will be back before you know it
until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
Cruise if you like what you heard in
this episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramseysolutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]